we've been telling you a lot about
bottlenecks at our nation's ports and
one reason is a lack of truck drivers to
haul cargo to customers the shortfall of
drivers is expected to grow reaching 100
000 by 2023 that's helping to drive the
industry's push towards an autonomous
future and it may not be that far away
errol barnett recently rolled in a
self-driving semi to see what's ahead
the world's hottest auto race has no one
behind the wheel burning through
millions of dollars truly autonomous
driving companies like too simple and
waymo are competing against a slew of
startups like aurora for the future of
our roads the aurora driver doesn't get
distracted it doesn't drive home after
having one too many drinks
it's not sleepy it's able to pay
attention the whole time ceo chris
erbson co-founded his company in 2017
and acquired uber's self-driving unit
last year ermsen's passenger models are
still being tested
but he's here in texas to tout his big
rigs
these more than 35 ton autonomous semi
trucks are now moving goods between
dallas and houston a first for their
client fedex the idea is that you'll be
able to tell it where you want to go and
just trust it and not pay attention to
it we hitched a ride in a test run on
the busy i-45 with the company's vp of
partner programs and there's the
acceleration yep because we've trained
it to operate like a human would fedex
runs have two safety drivers in the cab
it looks like we're about to turn
can you put your hands up that is
very interesting the key is its guidance
system comprised of several mounted
cameras plus radar and lidar which uses
lasers to read the road here's how the
lidar imaging works things moving
towards the center show up as green and
blue things moving away are yellow
orange and red creating this real-time
virtual highway which instructs the
system to accelerate turn or stop and
there we go so we're taking that lane
change to the left to pass the slow
moving vehicle 2023 is aurora's target
to hit the road without any drivers
there's another truck coming right to
our left so it decided not to take that
lane change because it saw it
if i'm a ride share driver or a truck
driver right now am i watching my
replacement no
definitely not there are driver
shortages right and so there is way more
demand than there is supply public trust
is another issue after the first
pedestrian death caused by a
self-driving car in 2018 faith in
autonomous systems was shaken is 2023 a
realistic goal for this company i have
my doubts about that former ntsb
chairman robert sumwalt says government
approval will rely on fail fail-safes
the real key there will be making sure
that you've got
multi-redundant systems that will be
critical but these systems are actually
developed by humans and the human
developers can't always anticipate each
and every scenario there are actually
some pretty crazy things that happen on
the streets in texas when the system saw
a person walking their dog along the
highway we did witness the truck change
lanes unlike its human counterparts
we've built this system to operate
safely and with conviction but
courteously as well
proving the polite potential of an
automated world the cbs mornings i'm
errol barnett in palmer texas
you know pretty impressive but if you're
going to if you pull up alongside it and
you go like this does it make a sound
no it's the big changes
but what we all want is safety and when
you look at what they're doing they seem
to know exactly they seem to have
mastered it i just think the public
isn't there yet but i think we could all
get there well the ceo chris armstrong
said um tell it what to do yes trust it
and not pay attention to it it's hard
not to pay attention to a semi truck
without a driver it's a trusted part
yeah okay i i still have questions but
we'll monitor it yeah all right thank
you errol